[Music]
two facts one I define myself as a black
man first because that's what you're
gonna see when you look at me being gay
is something I define myself second
third I can't decide really but it's not
everything I am it's a part of the
complexity that I am and that's not
backing away from the fact that I'm gay
it's just that there are other aspects
of my personality which are much more
important to me and how I negotiate the
world my career in the UK and other
parts of the world really came about
because someone there saw my talent at
being able to talk about money
personal finance cultural issues and my
curiosity and opened the door for me I
don't think that I would have had the
same opportunity in the United States
why not partly because when people look
at me they don't see my skill sets and
they're always filtered through their
own prejudice in the UK in other parts
of the world not all but many people
will give you credit they'll give you
the opportunity even if it's the
opportunity to fail but it's an
opportunity that you can turn into
success I don't think that what happened
with my career in the United Kingdom
would have happened for me in America I
don't think that the affection that the
people in the UK have for me would
come to me in America I think that
people saw my curiosity saw my hunger
saw my ability to talk about things
honestly and openly and genuinely and
they appreciated that I don't I will
never know why we couldn't convince
Americans to embrace that side of me and
many years ago I stopped wondering I
just stopped when I use the term code I
mean when people know and don't know
they're bigoted racist or generally
prejudiced but they try to hide it so
you have to be aware of
I've movements hand gestures body
language even some time word choices
because that word choice can often
telescope to you suddenly exactly what
you're dealing with and often the people
who use those terms are so unaware but
they don't even know the import of what
they're saying but if you know then that
means you can adjust yourself to the
situation they are not likely to change
and you will gain nothing by calling
them out on it except next time it'll be
more subtle so often I see it I adjust
me because as I learned from that
therapist many years ago it's me I have
to change it's me I have to alter not
that
[Music]